hey guys how's it going so I recently
got the Apple pencil along with the iPad
pro as you guys know if you've seen a
couple of my videos and this is my
sister Brianne mr. Jenna Brianne is
extremely not tech savvy at all do you
even have a computer I just don't use it
okay
okay well we're gonna unbox the Apple
pencil do you want to open this up for
us sing kishke Shelfari TV show for you
tea shop where you take I'll use this
antler of course oh just coming near I
know the back ah he's got your name what
did you do to the box
oh I'm so glad I was an actual life
because I would prefer I would've
definitely enjoy my selfie i had bro
have you been hit me in the face as I'm
pretty awesome
I have watched an entire season of
Netflix today be careful there's there
dogs here it's not that much I watches
to the hundred I'm not spitting anything
i watch the hundred the whole first
season in less than 24 hours saying yeah
what do you think about this breed take
a look take a look at nd in the face
with it
I'm having a hard great big for your
keyboard
oh yeah a computer hey no what do you
think that's too big it is a too I
mean if we're watching a movie he's
another Apple product open up what do
you think of the audio sound Sheila okay
okay I'm unboxing the a pencil so here
we have copyright you're at home and
then we can do and I don't agree it
sharpens itself yeah you don't need a
have you already to powerful sharpener
you believe it it's crazy
yeah it just happens however and you're
pressing again hmm where do you look but
does it go down well look it even
charges itself with this lightning cable
if you want a white tip instead of a
black tip and there's like a little tab
where you pull it out
we house there's extra tips do you bring
what do you think of the pencil torso
would you give any language sharpen it
brands a pharmacist so when should you
write this write-ups with pens or
pencils
I don't worry oh I just take verbal so
pro burbles but this is Sydney said
don't write with pencils that's illegal
really yeah but exactly just live it
actually right on it's like that on
paper and pencil and tablets ah give me
turn it on no never it's on pick on
paper you don't write on paper no you
this is made from paper made from paper
can't we don't yes you can get a find
these papers see cuz you don't have a
tin all I'm reading have a tip now this
is the extra tip oh shoot hope this tip
this is the extra tip it comes with a
vengeance don't it oh it's not it
doesn't made for writing on iPad what
they made for it's an Apple pencil it's
like the new revolutionary way to what
write on paper no sharpening no necking
no let's so then licit dumb no when you
write you can write like so I'm gonna go
to your computer yo you it's the correct
listen see you write on paper and it
goes your computer look what okay so I'm
gonna write you a secret note oh come on
okay just hold our own oh shoot okay so
then that does nothing no use the iPad
and then when you take a picture of it
it'll come up yeah it's awesome
oh no oh yeah boy don't look Geoffrey
okay no it's the way does it turn into
text
yes watch it Ginobili it should show are
you right it's but you would be eraser
da
that's not anybody there was a plugin
yeah this is the plug this is the eraser
so huh look I mean you're full of crap
no you're full of crap watch I don't see
anything on okay sit in writings I have
to develop it
your line you develop it you guys
develop up that this is made for
mysteries may be printed that's that's
the slogan on Apple pencil made for me
look I'm gonna take this off picture of
it kevrah let's develop and it's gonna
know on flurry no I took two so watch
guys as you can see I erased all the
text from it no longer there look
everything that I wrote is gone well
where is the original more you wrote on
right there
there's refuse the crap out of it how
does it really work
we just told you I understand that frog
that's false
don't buy highly anticipated frogs yep
2,050 yeah right you no idea what you're
talking about
you don't know what's happening at all
do you know how does this work okay
Johan I'm actually not sure it did
someone on you charges the lightning
cable you plug it in here to charge it
let me tell you how cool this looks oh
my gosh this this is a weapon save your
money this sickle what this looks so
dumb
four reviews by Bree had coming soon
yeah save your money
no strike our juvenile it's charging you
can poke it on I'll remember the Harry
Potter stabbing of comic-con I do I'll
never forget look I was charging legen
off two dozen wool to do what to write
note that's why doesn't showed up you
already know now watch me web metal is
about that only one that's old oh I want
you it's true okay it's charge um show
your finger yeah but you can't draw lit
but oh you can't draw my good you can't
die like this so we're gonna do a
gallery this is gonna make drawing with
friends real fun that people play like a
many more we go right again I don't pin
cyl oh look how pretty that okay but
look I can
the harder I press the darker it is
that's a nice no it's nice right look I
can make my brush size smaller change
the color
you clap push hard and if I like I can
do this like make it look like I'm like
what's that one guy that beans like to
burn Bob Ross see actually a string has
they stream them on/off twitch now they
don't what do you know what did you
think he thinks to the pencil I think
you be easy not a lot that a lot this is
one no I'd rather died a long time ago
great I've been able to love this it's
not doing it is look it's lights and
light yellow if I push hard do you want
to try it I'd like to snow I'm good okay
it senses the pressure do you understand
what I'm saying to you yeah so look is
this you I have 3d touch that this new
iPad no it doesn't wow it's really
coming a long way mix start over wait
that doesn't have the 3d touch no oh oh
so their iPad pro 3 will have it I have
a look what I'm trying to tell you guys
is this consents pressure so can this
look no mean what I didn't actually
think about this pencil okay honestly I
don't need this I'm not an illustrator
so basic ground would advance this is
really not gonna lie to you
that's right to color my shirt I don't
need this but let me tell you what if
you're an illustrator and this is
something that you do for a living and
it would be cool by oh my god becomes or
if you're an expert drawing with friends
oh that's kind of cool
that's kind of cool don't get messed my
life I like that oh that's nice I like
that the app that I'm using is procreate
it is I know I read it when you click
there yeah he did I read it when you
first clicked on that watches smut and I
remembered smudge I'm pushing really
hard I'm probably gonna crack my screen
well thanks for watching guys let me
know if you got a pencil or if you know
anyone that has one let me not use it I
gotta use it I'm a beautiful artist do
you want in your stuff your stocking
something stopping but it only works
with the eye-popping stuff only Humphrey
works with the iPad pro so if I'm not
getting great it's only gonna work with
the iPad pro pencil
but this only works with the iPad pro
but it also works on paper it does work
on page does not work on paper and you
can do not develop it and you know we're
liars
oh my gosh look here we are great
picture now I could draw on it yeah
won't you see that use your finger yeah
but it doesn't sense pressure you're
doing a good job man you draw anything
yet
I know it's beautiful good works he'll
work okay so kind of cool I know it's
fun all right guys thanks for watching
we'll see you later